Una oleada de preguntas salieron de las bocas de los chicos
que el mundo pensaba que no estaban interesados.
Y ellos mismos tampoco sabían que les importaba.
Mientras escribían y discutían,
en lugar de ver las películas como mera ficción,
comenzaron a verse a ellos mismos.
Tengo una tía que es excelente narradora de historias.
En un momento, ella puede evocar imágenes
de sus carreras descalza en la Montaña de la Mesa, jugando a policías y ladrones.
Hace poco, ella me contó
que en 1948, dos de sus hermanas y mi padre
viajaron en barco a Israel sin mis abuelos.
Cuando los marineros se amotinaron para solicitar condiciones dignas,
fueron estas jovencitas quienes alimentaron a la tripulación.
Cuando mi padre murió yo tenía más de 40 años.
Él nunca mencionó ese viaje.
La madre de mi madre salió de Europa de prisa,
sin su esposo, pero con su hija de 3 años
y diamantes cosidos en el ruedo de su falda.
Luego de dos años de estar escondido,
mi abuelo apareció en Londres.
Nunca más volvió a estar bien.
Y callaron su historia a medida que él se integraba.
Mi historia comenzó en Inglaterra
con un borrón y cuenta nueva y el silencio de padres inmigrantes.
Tuve «Ana Frank», «El gran escape»,
«Shoah», «El triunfo de la voluntad».
Fue Leni Riefenstahl
con su elegante propaganda nazi
quien dio contexto a lo que mi familia tuvo que soportar.
Estas películas contenían lo que era muy doloroso de decir en voz alta
y fueron más útiles para mí
que los susurros de los sobrevivientes
y el ocasional vistazo a un tatuaje
en la muñeca de una tía soltera.
Los puristas pueden pensar que la ficción disipa
la búsqueda de un entendimiento realmente humano,
que el cine es muy burdo como
para relatar una historia compleja y detallada
o que los directores de cine ponen siempre el drama por sobre la verdad.
Pero en los carretes está el propósito y el significado.
Como decía una niña de 12 años luego de ver «El mago de Oz»,
«Todas las personas deben ver esto,
porque si no lo hacen
puede que no sepan que también tienen corazón».
Respetamos la lectura, ¿por qué no respetar también el cine con la misma pasión?
Pensemos que el «Ciudadano Kane» es tan valioso como Jane Austen.
Acordemos que «Los dueños de la calle» tanto como Tennyson,
ofrecen un panorama emocional y un entendimiento
intensificado que funcionan juntos.
Cada pieza de arte de antología
es un ladrillo en el muro de lo que somos.
Y está bien si recordamos mejor a Tom Hanks
que al astronauta Jim Lovell
o tenemos la imagen de Ben Kingsley superpuesta a la de Gandhi.
Y Eve Harrington, Howard Beale, Mildred Pierce, aunque no son reales,
nos ofrecen la oportunidad de descubrir
lo que significa ser humano
y no es menos útil que comprender nuestra vida y nuestro tiempo
como Shakespeare al iluminar el mundo de la Inglaterra isabelina.
Supusimos que el cine
cuyas historias son un punto de reunión
del drama, la música, la literatura y la experiencia humana,
acogerían e inspirarían a los jóvenes a que participaran en FILMCLUB.
Lo que no nos imaginábamos
eran las notables mejoras
en el comportamiento, confianza y logros académicos.
Los estudiantes, reacios de antes, ahora corren a la escuela, hablan con sus profesores,
pelean, no en el patio de la escuela,
sino para elegir la próxima película de la semana,
jóvenes que se han autodefinido, tienen ambición
y apetito por una educación y un compromiso social,
a partir de las historias de las que han sido testigos.
Nuestros participantes desafían la descripción binaria
de cómo describimos con frecuencia a nuestros jóvenes.
No son salvajes ni están ensimismados de manera miope.
Son como otra gente joven
que negocia en un mundo con infinidad de opciones,
pero con poca cultura para encontrar una experiencia significativa.
Nos sorprendemos de los comportamientos
de aquellos que se definen a sí mismos
por las cosas que tienen,
aunque hemos ofrecido la narrativa como conocimiento.
Si queremos valores diferentes,
tenemos que contar otra historia,
una historia que entienda que la narrativa de un individuo
es un componente esencial de la identidad de una persona,
que una narrativa colectiva,
es un componente esencial de una identidad cultural,
y que sin esta, es imposible imaginarse uno mismo
como parte de un grupo.
Porque cuando estas personas regresan a casa
después de ver «La ventana indiscreta»
y levantan la mirada al edificio de al lado,
tienen las herramientas para adivinar quiénes, aparte de ellos,
están ahí afuera
y cuál es su historia.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)